preservar el medio ambiente y romper los
estereotipos de género Ese es el
objetivo de una empresa de autobuses
ubicada en la localidad bogotana de
Ciudad Bolívar la rolita es una compañía
de transporte que posee 195 autobuses
eléctricos y desde su inicio en
septiembre de 2022 ha ahorrado 6000
toneladas de dióxido de carbono además
con sus métodos de limpieza gasta 30%
menos que los sistemas tradicionales y
su agua es reutilizada es una flota 100%
sostenible es como haberle dado al
planeta por cada bus 2300 árboles
sembrados entonces en estos momentos
nosotros ya hemos dejado de emitir más
de 6000 toneladas de CO2 y para
diciembre creemos que vamos a tener más
de 10.000 toneladas de ahorro de CO2 que
eso es un aporte para el mundo por otro
lado la rolita también intenta avanzar
con una óptica de paridad de género en
un ambiente completamente masculinizado
en la actualidad al menos el 50% de su
plantilla de trabajadores son mujeres y
realizaron un sistema de capacitaciones
para actualizar licencias y desarrollar
nuevas habilidades Yo creo que con esta
propuesta
nosotras las mujeres vamos a dar un paso
más adelante de esa de esa perspectiva
machista que que lastimosamente Colombia
tiene de muchos años y ha sido muy
difícil tumbarla a pesar de tener solo
nueve meses de existencia esta empresa
de vehículos sustentables ofrece
servicio a 41.000 usuarios diarios
comunicando a 21 barrios a través de
once rutas la iniciativa Busca
expandirse otros medios de transporte
como el cable aéreo implementar
cargadores por automóviles y ocupar el
transporte escolares